nos cd appelle un traitement fiscal de
la philanthropie plus équilibrée entre
les pays
la réduction d'impôt sur les dons peut
atteindre 66% en france 45% en belgique
de 15 à 33 pour cent au canada au canada
d'ailleurs on compte 86 milles entité
philanthropique reconnu en 2017 il y a
eu 9 milliards 600 millions de dollars
de dons individuels au canada et 3
milliards 800 millions de dollars de
dons corporatifs pascal saint-amans et
directeur du centre de politique et
d'administration fiscales de l'oscd
bonsoir par pourquoi c'est important de
s'intéresser au traitement fiscal de la
philanthropie mais parce qu'on fait la
philanthropie
c'est à dire les dons sont faits à des
organismes sans but lucratif un rôle
très important dans la société en termes
économiques c'est 100 % du produit
intérieur brut mondial donc 5%
c'est c'est important et puis c'est
aussi quelque chose qui tient à coeur
aux citoyens aux différentes personnes
et qui leur permettent de contribuer à
des causes dans lesquelles ils croient
et donc la fiscalité un rôle important
sur le fait de diriger ces dons vers des
endroits qui sont comment dire accepter
par la société qui font partie des
objectifs sociaux de la société
et puis aussi la fiscalité a un impact
très fort sur le volume des dons mais
également sur la justice fiscale si on
permet aux plus riches de donner
beaucoup et en tirer un avantage très
important est beaucoup plus important
relativement que ce que peuvent faire
les pauvres qui vont contribuer peu en
valeur absolue mais en fait beaucoup en
valeur relative à la il ya des questions
d'équité fiscale à la clé et de façon
très intéressante on a réalisé avec
l'université de genève qui nous a
financé pour cette étude que il y avait
très peu d'études qui permettait de
faire le point sur la fiscalité de la
philanthropie dans le monde et c'est ce
qu'on a fait avec une étude qui couvre
plus de 40 pays et est ce qu'on constate
que la concurrence fiscale qu'on connaît
entre les pays s'implique également dans
le monde de l'au delà
philanthropie parce qu'on veut attirer
des dons de corporation de grandes
fondations alors pas vraiment une
fiscalité pas vraiment une concurrence
internationale il n'y a pas des pays qui
vont se dire venez chez moi vous aurez
des tâches peu importe en revanche au
sein de chaque pays
il ya des problématiques relatives quels
sont les secteurs qu'on favorise avec
une autre un autre aspect qui est liée à
l'accroissement des inégalités
aujourd'hui dans le monde au fait qu'on
a de plus en plus de milliardaires qui
eux mêmes on peut faire leur fortune en
s'échappant plus ou moins d'aidés des
systèmes fiscaux en ayant de l'évasion
fiscale et cet argent cumulé peut être
dépensé dans les causes qu'ils croient
les plus justes et là il ya une question
presque philosophique et aussi de
sciences politiques relatives à la
démocratie
est ce que on ne substitue pas la
volonté de quelques individus à la
volonté populaire à la volonté nationale
exprimée par le peuple via ses
représentants et donc quel est le bon
équilibre à trouver je crois que c'est
une des questions importantes qui se
pose une autre question qui est beaucoup
plus triviale moins philosophique c'est
que les organismes sans but lucratif
pour se financer parce qu'ils ont de
moins en moins ce dead de l'état ou des
collectivités publiques et bien se sont
aventurés dans des domaines commerciaux
regarder le nombre de musées qui offre
maintenant des restaurants et des
traitements restaurants bars et
restaurants est ce qu'ils doivent être
taxés ou pas est-ce qu'ils sont en
concurrence avec le restaurant qui est
de l'autre côté de la rue ou bas et donc
on voit qu on a pas mal de
problématiques qui peuvent être
philosophie qui peuvent être très
pratique trade économique etc sur
l'ensemble de ces de ces questions que
nous avons travaillé
est ce que le régime fiscal des
fondations privées de charité viennent
creuser un trou dans les finances
publiques des états et qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour que ces fondations
privées participent davantage au
financement public et au financement de
la crise of power
alors on fait
comment dire la question n'est pas
simple en tout cas je l'informerai pas
forcément de cette façon parce que les
fondations privées elle aide les états à
soutenir des secteurs notamment le
secteur de la santé actuellement avec la
pandémie et donc les aides privées qui
sont dirigés sur ce secteur qui sont
dirigés vers la recherche médicale la
recherche médicale dans tous les pays
dépend très largement des dons regarder
les téléthons et autres mécanismes pour
collecter beaucoup de dons c'est donc yz
en fait l'état et ils passent par des
fondations privées et donc les
fondations privées il faut pas qu'elle
se substitue à l'état
il faut qu'elles viennent soutenir
l'état d'où l'importance de fixer les
bons objectifs de la part des
gouvernements et des parlements sur
quels sont les secteurs qui sont
éligibles à des dons qui eux-mêmes
bénéficieront de réductions fiscales
et là il ya des techniques fiscales est
ce qu'il faut faire des déductions
fiscales est ce que je déduis mon revenu
ce que j'ai donné ou est-ce que j'ai
droit à un crédit d'impôt alors ça
paraît un peu technique mais en réalité
derrière il ya un avantage qui est plus
ou moins importants et donc on fait une
recommandation la pour dire ils font
insulter les dons à tous les niveaux
mais il faut pas donner un avantage trop
important aux personnes les plus riches
à défaut de quoi on introduit de
l'inéquité entre les gens donc il faut à
la fois efficaces dans la direction des
fonds et les fondations et z à ça mais
ne pas être trop généreux au bénéfice de
certains au détriment des autres un mot
en terminant sur un sujet sur lequel
vous travaillez depuis des années les
ministres des finances en france a
annoncé le début de la taxation des
géants du web cette semaine les
négociations de laisser des oeufs avec
140 pays pour trouver une entente
ces négociations ont été prolongées est
ce que vous pensez qu'on va y arriver en
et est ce que le changement de président
aux états unis va faciliter les choses
alors sur un deuxième question la
réponse est oui
en tout cas on aura je pense de la
clarté assez vite de la part de
l'administration buydens qui dira s'ils
veulent ou pas négocier une solution et
si oui quelle est la solution qui
veulent négocier c'est ce qu'attend des
partenaires des états unis et cévennes
ya les prémices il y avait eu une
construction positive et puis depuis un
an il y avait une sorte de désengagement
est ce qu'on aura une
solution je le souhaite je suis payé
pour ça donc faisons le point dans six
mois on a jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
pour trouver un accord parfait
on va suivre ça toujours avec beaucoup
d'intérêt pascal saint-amans merci merci
à vous